Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan. Ein frohes neues Jahr.
Ebenso.
Das wünschen wir auch allen, die uns zuhören.
Hoffentlich sind alle gesund reingerutscht. Ich ja nicht so diesmal.
Ja, aber die Ereignisse überschlagen sich.
Wolfgang Schäuble ist gestorben und du hattest getwittert, dass du es doch ein
bisschen eigenartig findest, wie auf diesen Tod reagiert wird.
Also man kann ja darüber traurig sein, dass jemand stirbt oder man kann Angehörigen
das Beileid aussprechen, entbieten, wie man früher sagte.
Aber es ist doch ganz erstaunlich, dass sobald in Deutschland irgendein Politiker
stirbt, sich alle Journalisten in den Bundespräsidenten verwandeln und dann kondolieren und sagen,
er war ein großer Demokrat,
der allergrößte Europäer.
Großer Europäer, großer Demokrat, großer Parlamentarier, großer Redner.
Alles.
Stimmt das, fragen wir uns, weil wir über die Austeritätspolitik nachdenken,
wie Wolfgang Schäuble Griechen und viele andere Millionen Menschen mit dieser
Austeritätspolitik in die Armut getrieben hat,
wie er den Griechen nahe legte, Inseln zu verkaufen oder ob man nicht Griechenland
gleich abstoßen kann, brauchen wir die überhaupt in der EU.
Ist das ein großer Europäer, fragt man sich da.
Zumindest sahen das ja vor Schäubles Tod noch einige anders,
aber sobald man stirbt ist man offenbar gleich auf einen Sockel gehoben.
Und ist er der Retter der Demokratie, weil er bis zum Schluss über Jahrzehnte
im Parlament saß und den Platz nicht freigemacht hat für irgendwelche anderen Neuen.
52 Jahre.
Ja, ist das ein Ausweis davon, dass er ein unglaublicher Demokrat ist?
Ich bin mir da unsicher. Also wenn man nicht jetzt lernt, ein Beileidsausdruck,
der sich an Angehörige widmet,
wenn man dazu nicht in der Lage ist, ihn zu trennen von einem politischen Nachruf,
dann brauchen wir eigentlich gar nicht mehr über irgendjemanden zu diskutieren.
Dann können wir immer danach sagen, war der der beste Mensch der Welt und das war es.
Also gerade muss man ja dann von journalistischer Seite kritisch auf so ein
politisches Leben und die Handlungen, die Taten dieses Lebens blicken.
Und dann würde sich ja herausstellen, dass wir es hier nicht mit dem allergrößten
Europäer zu tun haben, sondern mit jemand, der Europa ja sehr,
sehr stark demoliert hat.
Für mich steckt da auch der Tod so als Erlöser irgendwie drin.
Ja.
In unserer schrecklichen Welt, in der wir uns fast nichts mehr schönreden können
und 2024 einfach nur begrüßt wird mit, na hoffentlich ist es besser als 2023,
sucht man nach dem letzten Strohhalm der Erlösung. Und das ist so wenigstens beim Tod.
Ja.
Lässt man es dann zu, jetzt keine schlechten Worte. Denn ich hatte ja nicht
einfach nur getwittert. Ich hatte ja auf Georg Restle reagiert.
Ja.
Der ja sich beklagte darüber, dass angeblich irgendwo, und das war ja dann meine
Frage, so viel Negatives über Schäuble zu lesen sei, weil ich fand nichts.
Nein, nur bei Twitter einzelne User, die aber nicht aus dem politischen Betrieb
oder dem journalistischen Betrieb waren. Aber sonst hat man da nichts gefunden.
Ich kann auch verstehen, wenn Politiker von einem Kollegen Abschied nehmen und
sich da dann kollegial ausdrücken und sagen, es war immer eine angenehme Zusammenarbeit
trotz politischer Differenzen.
Dass sich das gehört im parlamentarischen Umgang ist völlig klar,
aber es ist nicht die Aufgabe dann von anderen Zeitgenossen jemanden im Nachruf
dann zur Ikone zu erklären.
Genau und es bekräftigt mich wieder, wir haben ja schon lange gerufen quasi
nach der Merkel Aufarbeitung, die wurde ja auch so abgefeiert,
nachdem sie ihren Amtstod erlitten hat.
Bei Schäuble ist es jetzt der biologische Tod und wieder kriegen wir keine ordentliche Aufarbeitung.
Denn gerade im Kontext des Buches, das wir heute lesen, des normalischen Jahrhunderts,
kann, also ich denke bei Schäuble zuallererst an seinen Fernsehauftritt irgendwann in den Jahren 2014.
15. Ja.
Als er bei Berlin direkt saß und sich fragte, naja klar weiß ich,
wie es in Spanien und Portugal zugeht, aber die haben da auch 30,
40 Prozent Jugendarbeitslosigkeit. Ja, warum kommen die nicht zu uns?
So, und diese Frage, wo er so sagt, ich verstehe nicht, warum die nicht einfach
zu uns kommen, um ihr Leben aufzubauen, ist ja so eine ganz zentrale,
die lange bevor wir Heimatdiskussionen mit Horst Seehofer als bayerischer und
dann für Deutschland zuständiger Heimatminister wurde und so weiter,
wo wir so Fragen haben wie,
naja, aber warum sollten sie wegziehen?
Nur weil es ökonomisch nicht läuft, ist in Ökonomie alles, also wenn ich irgendwo
mehr Geld verdiene, ziehe ich automatisch dahin.
Das zum einen und zum anderen war das einer der seltenen Momente,
wo man so dachte als Zuschauer, ach interessant, das ist also die eigentliche Strategie.
Man sieht die demografische Wende vor Deutschland und richtet jetzt Südeuropa
zugrunde in der Hoffnung, dass dann ein, zwei, drei Millionen junge Menschen
sagen, okay, da gehe ich halt nach Deutschland,
weil diese Erfahrung hat ja Westdeutschland schon mal gemacht mit den Ostdeutschen.
Ja.
Also man hatte die Erfahrung eines politischen Jungbrunnens und suchte also,
da er verebte, 20 Jahre nach der Einheit, den Nächsten.
So, und da da lag das plötzlich so brach.
Also diese Frage, ich verstehe nicht, warum, ich such den Clip auch wahrscheinlich
nochmal raus für unsere Monatsfolge, ich verstehe nicht, warum die nicht einfach zu uns kommen.
Es scheint für mich so ein ganz seltener Moment zu sein, wo,
Derselbe Wortlaut im Fernsehstudio und im Fraktionsdiskurs sozusagen Ablauf.
Und das ist für mich Schäuble. Immer dieses doppelte Spiel irgendwie.
Ich bin der Große, eigentlich bin ich der bessere Kanzler.
Eigentlich bereichere mich mal kurz an 100.000 Mark. So, dieses Wechselspiel.
Aber dieser Art von Nachruf traut sich keiner zu.
Dadurch, finde ich, geht auch so ein bisschen so eine Leitfadendiskussion.
Wie gehen wir eigentlich mit den heute 25- und 30-Jährigen im Parlament um,
die da auch noch drohen, 50 Jahre lang zu sitzen?
Wir haben also gar keine Diskussion über Maßstäbe. Worum sollte es eigentlich mal gehen?
Ja, man darf schon gespannt sein, wie wird es denn sein, wenn mal wichtige AfD-Politiker
sterben? Sagt man dann auch?
Ein großer Patriot, ein Weltbürger oder was sagt man da?
Er hat es ja nicht so gemeint oder was?
Ja, oder ein Konservativer mit dem Herz am rechten Fleck, irgendwie sowas.
Also man hat mal wieder eine große Chance in Deutschland verpasst,
so ein reflexives, unkonstruktives politisches Moment herbeizuführen.
Ja und Nachrufe richten sich nicht an die Angehörige. Das ist nicht geschrieben
für die Enkel von Wolfgang Schäuble,
sondern das ist für die Öffentlichkeit geschrieben und die Öffentlichkeit muss
sich kritisch zu den Politikern verhalten, wenn sie leben und auch in der Nachbetrachtung
ihres politischen Lebens. Viertens, darum geht es.
Es geht ja nicht darum zu sagen, Gott sei Dank sind wir los,
sondern es geht darum zu sagen, dieser Politiker hat Folgendes gemacht und dann
fallen einem bei Wolfgang Schäuble, denke ich, doch einige Dinge ein,
die nicht so großartig sind für junge Menschen,
für Europäer, für Griechen etc.
Demokraten.
Für Demokraten und...
Sollte man nicht auf dieses Menschelnde gehen, denn das war interessant,
was du dann ja bei so Leuten wie Micky Beisenherz oder so bei Twitter erleben
kannst, dass du dann gesagt hast, ja, aber hier war er besonders lustig und ja, man findet bei jedem,
irgendwelche lustigen Momente und ja, Schäuble muss wohl sehr kollegial gewesen
sein und ich könnte dann auch nochmal twittern, er war einer der wenigen Politiker,
der auch neue klassische Musik gehört hat und dem das immer wichtig war,
aber ist das jetzt gerade so entscheidend oder geht es eher um das politische Gesamtwerk.
Ja, wir sind ja hier ein Indie-Podcast, das heißt, wir sind keiner Verlagshaltung,
Blattlinie erlegen und deswegen will ich folgenden Punkt machen.
Dem einzigen, dem ich das zugestehe, sind Chiffre-Figuren wie Gregor Gysi,
die zwar von einer anderen politischen Richtung kommen, aber dann trotzdem noch
so leicht lobhudelnd schreiben, weil man da ich zumindest immer den impressionistischen
Unterton habe, er sagt uns schon mal an, wie ein Nachruf aussieht.
Jaja, das ist bei Gysi, er würde sich glaube ich gerne seinen eigenen schon mal schreiben.
Aber bei so Figuren wie Georg Ressler, auch wieder Schiffre, Georg Ressler,
ich will keine Mahnung auf Twitter oder R-Mahnung, dass ich jetzt bitte an die
Familie Wolfgang Schäuble denken muss.
Sondern das muss ich in dem Moment nicht. Ich kenne die Familie ja gar nicht.
Ich kenne auch Wolfgang Schäuble nicht.
Ich kenne den privaten, persönlichen Wolfgang Schäuble nicht.
Ich kenne nur den Politiker Wolfgang Schäuble.
Und über den möchte ich gerne im Rahmen seiner Politiker-Tätigkeit Nachrufe lesen.
Und zwar so, dass ich denke, ja, den sollte man auch nochmal anderen zum Lesen geben.
Und da brauche ich keine sozusagen Fan-Fiction-Literatur.
In dem Moment, in der er sich schade Chance verpasst.
Sprechen wir noch über eine andere Personalie. Fabio De Masi geht in die Wagenknecht-Partei.
Und wie finden wir das? Wie finden wir das? Bekenne dich Wolfgang,
ich bekenne mich auch gleich.
Du bekennst dich, okay, dann fange ich mal an. Also viele waren gestern enttäuscht
und wenn ich jetzt aber viele sage, dann meine ich eigentlich nur ein paar Tweets,
die ich gelesen habe und eigentlich kann ich gar nicht sagen,
ob jemand tatsächlich enttäuscht ist.
Ich finde es erst einmal interessant, dass er es macht, ich hätte nicht unbedingt damit gerechnet.
Wir können uns ja jetzt erstmal diesem Thema Fabio De Masi, ein sehr seriöser,
anerkannter Experte in Sachen Ökonomie, Finanzen,
wir können uns ja dem mal langsam nähern und können jetzt mal fragen,
also wir haben jetzt Europawahlen, wir haben vor allem diese Wahlen im Osten,
und was könnte also das Schlimmste sein, was passiert? Ja, dass die AfD...
Die Mehrheit bekommt. Das ist das Schlimmste, was anzunehmen ist.
Ich glaube, darauf können sich alle einigen, außer jetzt AfD-Wähler.
Und dann kann man also festhalten, was diesen Aufstieg verhindert.
Der AfD ist zunächst einmal vielleicht nicht so schlecht, das kleinere Übel
oder vielleicht sogar gut.
Also insofern könnte man diese ganze Wagenknecht-Partei schon mal einordnen,
also schafft die es, der AfD in Thüringen oder Sachsen 10% abzuluchsen,
dann wäre ja vielleicht schon etwas gewonnen.
Jetzt bin ich nicht jemand, der De Masi über den grünen Klee loben will,
weil ich mir geschworen habe, nie Politiker großartig zu loben,
denn man wird ja am Ende von ihnen doch enttäuscht.
Ich habe bei einem Vortrag vor ein paar Monaten Hubertus Heil gelobt und jetzt
führt er Sanktionen ein, habe ich mich jetzt schon wieder geschämt.
Also man muss aufpassen mit Lob für Politiker.
Aber De Masi ist ein ausgezeichneter Experte, der auch über die Parteigrenzen
hinweg immer gelobt wird für tolle Zusammenarbeit und für seinen Input.
Was könnte jetzt jemand wie De Masi, wenn er zurück in die Politik kehren will,
tun? Er könnte ja nur noch zu zwei Parteien, also nicht zu der Linken,
da ist er ja ausgetreten, jetzt wieder dahin, wäre merkwürdig.
Er kann zu den Grünen gehen, da würde er aber keinen Blumentopf gewinnen,
da könnte er dann auch irgendwann sagen, wir brauchen mal Waffenexporte nach
Saudi-Arabien für Lisas Kinder. Er könnte in die SPD gehen.
Was soll er da machen? Das nächste Sanktionspaket für Bürgergeldempfänger vorbereiten.
Also da ist ja auch kein Weg für ihn möglich.
Der Schritt jetzt in Wagenknechts Partei zu gehen, wird jetzt so sehr als No-Go dargestellt.
Aber die Tatsache ist doch, dass wir vielleicht mal überlegen sollten,
wie ordnen wir jetzt diese Partei ein.
Also, Wagenknecht ist natürlich eine Figur, die, um es mild auszudrücken, sehr schillernd ist.
Aber was ja zum Teil herbeigeschrieben wird, ist, also Wagenknecht wird da eine
Querdenker-Partei machen.
Da kommen Dieter Dehm und Ulrike Gero und mit denen macht die dann den Laden.
Danach sieht es ja offenbar jetzt gerade nicht aus, wenn der ehemalige Bürgermeister
von Düsseldorf im Team vorne mit dabei ist und jetzt Fabio De Masi.
Das heißt, offenbar findet diese Radikalisierung, die da vorher beschrieben
wurde, personell erst einmal nicht statt.
Das heißt, hier findet eine Mäßigung statt und es könnte sein,
dass man also versucht, auf einen möglichst seriösen Weg zu gehen und nimmt
deshalb Kräfte wie De Masi oder den ehemaligen SPD-Bürgermeister von Düsseldorf.
Das heißt, was möchte man dann jetzt eigentlich?
Man möchte zum einen sagen, dass die Wagenknecht-Partei unmöglich ist.
Seht her, die werden noch die Giro an die Spitze stellen.
Jetzt macht die Wagenknecht-Partei das nicht und nimmt jemanden wie De Masi,
der ja vermutlich dann für Europa sich aufstellen lassen wird.
Hat er ja oder will er ja.
In einem Querdenker-Lager anzusiedeln ist, sondern eher in dem,
und jetzt sage ich diesen Begriff, ich glaube, wir werden den nächsten Jahren
noch sehr häufig hören, in dem Spektrum des Linkskonservatismus.
Dafür brauchen wir nochmal einen neuen Begriff, denn das Wort links will ich
da gar nicht mehr unterbringen, so wie ich auch das Wort alles,
was mit rechts zu tun hat, mittlerweile entwertet sehe.
Denn wenn wir jetzt von der rechtsextremen Regierung in Israel sprechen und
vom Verfassungsschutz als gesichert rechtsextrem eingeschätzt und so weiter,
das kann man ja auch alles gar nicht mehr hören.
Wir brauchen da neue Worte. Geschichte wiederholt sich dann doch nicht.
Das sieht nur so aus, aber hier könnte man durch nochmal so einen semantischen
Mitvollzug dieser neuen strukturellen Entwicklung anregen.
Aber ich habe jetzt auch erstmal keinen Vorschlag.
Bei De Masi finde ich interessant, dass sich jetzt so viele wundern.
Das heißt ja schon mal viel.
Denn De Masi ist aus dieser Fraktion ausgetreten auf eigene Faust.
Es gab also sehr viel Ärger in dieser Linksfraktion, ohne dass man das jetzt
auf so einen großen Lagerkampf wagenknecht gegen den Rest der Welt oder so,
sondern man konnte auch aus freien Stücken einfach sagen, nee, das ist total doof.
Und wir haben ja den Abschiedstext von De Masi damals auch gelesen,
im Salon oder im Podcast, weil er so ein paar innerliche Anmerkungen hat zum
Thema, was wir ja auch sehr sympathisch finden, ökonomische,
Debattenführung im politischen Felde. Und da sind die Linken nicht gut aufgestellt.
So, und jetzt überrascht er uns damit, dass er sich sehr viel später doch in
dieses Lager wieder einreiht, und zwar nicht auf Seiten der Linken,
sondern auf Seiten Wagenknechts.
Was für mich bedeutet, ich bin großer DiMasi-Fan, Wagenknechts Buch haben wir
besprochen, fanden wir bescheuert, sonst kam da auch nicht viel,
ihre YouTube-Shows finde ich völlig belanglos, also ich weiß gar nicht,
warum das so viele Leute gucken.
Ich bin also als Anhänger Demarsis jetzt mitgezogen und sage mir,
ja klar will ich den Europaparlament sehen. Ich bin jetzt hin und her gerissen zwischen,
Patrick Breyer wählen von den Piraten oder Fabio De Masi, von welcher Partei
auch immer, wie sie dann heißt.
Das sind für mich jetzt so die entscheidenden Fragen.
Ich freue mich auch auf Talkshows. Ich will gerne ein De Masi da sitzen haben,
der dann irgendeinem AfD- oder CDU-Politiker mal erklärt, wie das eigentlich
so mit der Schuldenbremse sich verhält.
Genau, das fand ich jetzt auch interessant aus persönlicher Erfahrung.
Mein Besuch bei Lanz, also die Lanz-Sendung selbst, hat natürlich so das ein
oder andere Medien-Echo gefunden.
Und es ist wahnsinnig interessant zu sehen, wie sehr beispielsweise die Bild-Zeitung
auf den JU-Chef abstellt, nur weil er der JU-Chef ist. Ja.
Also das ist sinnlos, das Zitat wird einfach gebracht, nur um nochmal zu sagen,
das ist übrigens die Meinung der Jungen Union, weil wir wollen alle wissen,
was denken die Jungen Union und so.
Und von daher ist es absolut richtig, dass Fabio Di Masi seine,
und er war ja nun nicht still die letzten Monate, er hat sich ja aus allen Holzbracken
nochmal zuschalten lassen, sobald das Fernsehen nachfragte,
wenn man das nochmal mit so einer normativen Wucht unterfüttert,
indem er einfach parteizugehörig ist oder vielleicht sogar Mandatsträger.
Ja, so, man muss also, finde ich, gar nicht jetzt groß eine Aussage über Wagenknecht,
Wagenknechts Anliegen, Wagenknechts Partei, Wagenknecht, Wagenknecht,
Wagenknecht sagen, sondern man kann sich einfach darüber freuen,
dass man die Masi wieder wählen kann.
Dass er wieder normativ sozusagen verpflanzt und verwurzelt werden kann,
wo man einfach eine Struktur hat und weiß, ah, den kann man auch wählen,
also ein echtes Häkchen an seinen Namen setzen und so.
Man muss ja auch einem Menschen, der sich als Integer erwiesen hat und der auch
mit Können und Wissen von sich reden machte, dem muss man ja auch ein gewisses
Vertrauen entgegen bringen.
Man kann ja jetzt nicht sagen, oh jetzt ist der wohl auch abgetrifftet,
also so war dann gestern bei Twitter zu lesen, so als hätte jetzt De Masi sich
auch noch die Impfung irgendwie rausspritzen lassen wieder oder so.
Ausgezogen oder was? Also da würde ich sagen, kann man vielleicht mal einen Gang runterschalten.
Also man sollte Wagenknecht und auch diese Partei, denn noch hat sie ihr Programm
nicht vorgestellt, kritisieren, wenn dort Positionen zu Migrations- und Asylpolitik sind,
die zu verachten sind, die abzulehnen sind.
Und ich will das nur sagen, Ole und ich haben da 30 Minuten über die Migrationsposition
von Wagenknecht geredet bei
Wohlstand für Alle und die ist nicht gut weggekommen, Frau Wagenknecht.
Aber man kann jetzt nicht so tun, als sei Wagenknecht die schlimmste Populistin,
die wir jemals hatten und steht auf einer Ebene mit Höcke.
Also da muss man jetzt auch vielleicht mal einen Gang zurückschalten.
Ich würde es mal anders formulieren.
Es kann sich ja mal jeder selbst befragen, ob Wagenknecht wirklich unseriöser
ist als Christian Lindner, Markus Söder oder Friedrich Merz.
Oder schauen wir doch auf Everybody Starling bei der Heute-Show.
Philipp Amthor. Also Philipp Amthor hat schon einige Skandale am Hals,
hat Aussagen rassistischerweise getroffen, etc.
Wir müssen ja nicht alles hier
auflisten. Wird aber trotzdem von der Heute-Show die ganze Zeit hofiert.
Klar, da machen die sich ein bisschen lustig, der älteste Bundestagsabgeordnete, hahaha.
Aber eigentlich wird er die ganze Zeit hofiert, während die Heute-Show Wagenknecht
dämonisiert, dass man meint, das scheint die schlimmste Person der Welt zu sein.
Und ich sag mal so, Und bei Amthor wäre ich mir nicht so sicher,
wo der noch alles so politisch handelt und was der noch alles so mitmacht.
Also der hat auch schon sehr viel geäußert, aber offenbar ist,
weil er bei der CDU ist, dass dann doch einer von uns.
Und da würde ich doch sehr von abraten von dieser Verunglimpfung.
Und ich bin einfach gespannt, ob durch De Masi jetzt ein anderer wirtschaftlicher
Einfluss auf die Wagenknecht-Partei sichtbar wird,
dass man vielleicht auch mal über Schulden und all das anders nachdenkt,
weil da waren ja jetzt die Äußerungen, die man so gehört hat,
noch nicht besonders interessant.
Interessant, Wagenknecht muss weiterhin kritisch betrachtet werden und De Masi
muss auch kritisch betrachtet werden für das, was er jetzt da im Folgenden tun wird, aber ich glaube,
dass der politische Diskurs und auch der Diskurs um Wirtschaft beispielsweise
in Talkshows nicht unbedingt blöder wird, wenn ein De Masi da sitzt,
sondern das Gegenteil wird der Fall sein.
Und da können sich ja die anderen mal wieder positionieren und ich glaube auch,
dass De Masi jemand ist jetzt vom Charisma, der bei vielen sehr gut ankommt,
die auch im eher bürgerlichen Lager sonst zu Hause sind.
Über Fabio De Masi werden ja lange vor seinem Ableben schon Texte geschrieben
aus allen Himmelsrichtungen, in dem seine Expertise gelobt wird,
gerade bei Wirecard und wie er Scholz da unter Druck setzt.
Das sind ja die richtigen Themen. Ich warte auch, wann Fabian Köster und Philipp
Abentor gemeinsam auf Tour gehen, denn das ist wirklich pervers,
was man da mittlerweile in den sozialen Medien sieht von den beiden.
Wie kann das sein? Das ist doch ein Politiker, von dem man sagen würde,
nein, der vertritt schlimme rechte Positionen, das will man nicht und der hat
auch sonst einiges in der Vergangenheit angerichtet.
Ja, das ist mir auch unklar. Zu die Masi zwei Punkte noch.
Die Demokratie lebt ja von zwei großen Prinzipien. Das eine ist der Kompromiss
und das andere ist die Repräsentativität.
Kompromiss bedeutet, ja, jeder hat eigene Vorlieben bei den Themen des politischen
Feldes, man kriegt aber nicht alle durch.
Man muss also schon mal im Kopf anfangen, so einen Kompromiss zu planen und
da muss man sich einfach angucken bei Wagenknecht, was ist denn zu erwarten?
Wird es da Sachen geben, die man ablehnt? Ja, kann man sich vorstellen,
sich trotzdem von denen repräsentieren zu lassen, denn es vererbt sich eben
nicht eins zu eins. Von wem will man repräsentiert werden?
Und da sollte man sich keine falsche Vorstellung machen. Das Wort von Dietmar
Daat, es ist ein Partizipationstheater, gilt.
Alle glauben, sie hätten hier irgendwas mit zu sagen und so,
aber nein, wir sind nur eine von 60 Millionen Wahlstimmen.
Wer kann sie denn am besten für uns repräsentieren? Und dann kann man einfach
überlegen, ist es De Masi oder jemand anders?
Und wenn jemand anders ist, wählt man jemand anders. Wenn Fabio De Masi der
Beste ist, kann man ihn jetzt wieder wählen.
Aber es gibt darüber hinaus keine weiteren Alternativen, außer die,
die auf dem Wahlzettel stehen.
Das ist immer ganz wichtig. Ja, nur wenn man sich noch mehr wünscht,
heißt das nicht, dass es irgendwo noch, sondern es ist leider beschränkt auf
den Wahlzettel, egal wie das Partizipationstheater drumherum stattfindet.
Man kann dann alles dazu twittern, aber der Wahlzettel ist das Limit dieser
Welt, politisch gesehen. und nur, was da draufsteht, kann man auch wählen.
Also sollten wir uns, glaube ich, insgesamt mehr freuen, dass Fabio De Masi
demnächst wieder zu wählen ist.
Ob man ihn dann wählt, muss dann jeder anhand der Alternativen selbst entscheiden.
Aber Repräsentation und Kompromiss. Und den Kompromiss ruhig schon mal im Kopf einfach machen.
Und du kannst ja nicht eine De Masi-Partei basteln.
Du kannst jetzt nicht sagen, ja, De Masi wäre toll und jetzt bastel ich mir
so drumherum, wie diese Partei aussieht und dann brauche ich nur noch dem Masi
eine E-Mail schreiben, bitte gründen Sie folgende Partei. Ich habe mir da was ausgedacht.
Jetzt zum Jahresende war ja wieder, endlich mal wieder, nach dreimal Pause Chaos
Communication Kongress.
Das ist ja eine Veranstaltung, zu der geht man hin und denkt sich,
oh, das läuft aber ganz schön geschmeidig und cool hier und es ist halt so, wie es ist.
Und dann kommt vielleicht doch nochmal der ein oder andere Wunsch auf.
Und dann kann man die an die Orga herantreten und dann sagen die, ja, mach doch.
Wenn man sich da wünscht, dass es irgendwie bunter zugeht, sauberer,
leiser, lauter, interessanter, wie auch immer, ist die Antwort einfach, ja, mach doch.
Und so ist das auch in der Politik. Man kann sich keine Fabio-Di-Masi-Partei basteln.
Und doch kann man. Aber man muss es dann halt machen.
Man kann aber nicht daneben stehen und sich das einfach wünschen.
Weil dann ist man im Felde der Manifestation. Das funktioniert dann nicht.
Man muss es machen. Und wenn man es nicht macht, hat man halt keine.
Und jetzt gibt es halt welche, die machen es.
Und wenn man dann sagt, es ist aber nicht gut, wie die Wagenknecht das macht,
dann muss man einfach sagen, ja, das ist Demokratie. Dann mach selber besser.
Und solange du es nicht selber, also wer macht, hat Recht.
Und wenn man es nicht selber besser macht, ist man halt auf die Alternativen
angewiesen, die auf dem Wahlzettel dann münden.
Und da entsteht ja auch noch eine ganz neue Alternative offenbar mit Markus
Krall und Hans-Georg Maaßen und der Werteunion.
Da kann einem ja auch Angst und Wange werden, was das jetzt wieder ist.
Also das soll eine Partei sein, die zwischen AfD und CDU steht,
wo wir ja aber eigentlich schon aus den Stadträten und so weiter bei der CDU
wissen, da passt ja schon zwischen sie und die AfD nichts mehr.
Also welche Lücke die da nochmal ausmachen.
Viele sagen, es sei dann einfach ein Steigbügelhalter für die AfD,
dass man nochmal versucht, so ein CDU-Lager abzuwerben, das noch nicht den Schritt
geht, die AfD selbst zu wählen und man wählt dann die Wegbereiter der AfD,
aber man hat quasi noch so ein CDU-Gesicht wie Hans-Georg Maaßen dazu.
Also es ist jetzt nur meine Fanfiction zu diesem Szenario, aber es sieht wie
folgt aus, also von mir aus gedacht, aber vielleicht hat es eine gewisse Plausibilität.
Und Maaßen kann nicht direkt in die AfD einsteigen, weil dann wäre es irgendwie,
er war ja doch mal Verfassungsschutzpräsident und so.
Also klären die einfach intern, wie kannst du denn die CDU am meisten schaden.
Und dann sagt der Krah, ich habe doch gesagt, die sollen irgendwie zertrümmert werden, egal wie.
Und dann sagt er, naja, dann gehe ich in die ostdeutschen Regionen und grabe
da noch so ein bisschen am rechten Rand der CDU weg.
Es geht ja also nicht darum, dass sich das rechte Feld irgendwie spaltet und
balkanisiert wie das linke Lager und dann nichts mehr wird, sondern das verbuche ich komplett hoch.
Ja.
Unter einer AfD-Strategie, um sozusagen im Parteivorfeld die CDU weiter zu zertrümmern.
Weil wenn man sich anschaut, wie in meiner Ursprungsheimat Thüringen dieser
CDU-Landesverband aufgestellt ist, der sich eigentlich schon in der AfD verwandelt hat.
Aber halt CDU als Label trägt und das einfach nicht abschütteln kann,
so seine Wähler eigentlich schon vorbereitet hat auf inhaltlich,
ja, ihr seid quasi gezwungen, wenn ihr unsere Anhänger seid,
uns nicht zu wählen, sondern den echten Alternativen für Deutschland dann die
Stimme zu geben, da passt das für mich komplett ins Bild.
Der hat ja jetzt in Thüringen, da da in Suhl antrat und Bundestagsabgeordneter
werden wollte, die richtigen Verbindungen geknüpft und dann hat man sich einfach
das als Strategie ausgedacht und jetzt wird das halt so durchgezogen.
Ja und auch hier wieder Realpolitik, es ist so wie es ist, es sei denn man geht
selbst hinein, ändert es und zumindest kann man wählen, aber auch da nochmal
zu schauen, welche große Gefahr besteht da eigentlich,
nämlich genau diese, dass der Aufstieg der AfD zum einen dadurch geschieht,
dass die AfD gewählt wird und zum anderen da sich nochmal eine neue Partei gründet,
die dann sich anschließen wird an die AfD und wie du es jetzt gerade so schön
sagst, ist Es findet keine Balkanisierung statt,
das macht diese AfD ja auch so stark oder macht die Rechten so stark,
dass sie am Ende wunderbar alle zusammen arbeiten können.
Also Hans-Georg Maaßen und ein Krah und eine Weide können am Ende an einem Tisch
sitzen und werden sich darin einig sein, dass sie die Macht haben müssen gemeinsam.
Während wir das bei linken, linksliberalen Lagern überhaupt nicht vorfinden.
Da werden jetzt schon von ehemaligen Kollegen von De Masi gesagt,
ja er war immer ein Narzisst und so weiter.
Also man kann das Spiel jetzt weiter treiben, aber wir sehen diese andere Gefahr und die Frage ist dann,
was erachtet man jetzt gerade als Wichtige an,
also ist das auch jetzt journalistisch das, was man begleiten will die ganze Zeit,
wie reden jetzt irgendwelche Linke und jetzt kann man nochmal SPD-Politiker
aus Düsseldorf befragen, was die dazu sagen, dass der ehemalige Bürgermeister
nun doch zu Wagenknecht und so, das Spiel kann man jetzt lange treiben?
Krah und Designen werden sich das mit Vergnügen ansehen und werden stärker und stärker werden.
Also ich will jetzt hier nicht einfach so eine plumpe Einheit aufmachen und
sagen, ja wir müssen jetzt mal alle an einem Strang ziehen und so.
Es hat ja auch Gründe, warum eine Linke zersplitterter ist, weil dort eine ganz
andere Weise Intellektualität auch gelebt wird und Auseinandersetzung diskutiert wird.
Ich glaube nur, dass mit diesen Streitigkeiten,
die da die ganze Zeit ausgetragen werden und öffentlich gemacht werden,
dass man damit überhaupt nicht in irgendeiner Richtung weiterkommt,
sondern ich glaube, das ist auch immer ein sehr starkes Signal dafür,
dass man eigentlich nichts anzubieten hat.
Dass man eigentlich nichts anzubieten hat, wir sehen das jetzt gerade bei der
Ampel, die nackt dasteht, die mit Sanktionen kommt oder jetzt wird den Bauern
doch wieder mehr Geld gegeben und ist aber immer noch nicht genug und man macht alle unglücklich,
Alleinerziehende bekommen noch weniger Geld als sie vorher hatten jetzt durch die Reform.
Also da ist man schon nackt und wenn man jetzt von denen, die noch nicht an
der Regierung sind, auch eigentlich nur erfährt, ja aber die steht dem Lager
nah und der steht dem Lager nah,
dann sieht das ziemlich düster aus und ich empfehle da einfach mal ein Buch
zu lesen, zum Beispiel das Nomadische Jahrhundert,
um vielleicht mal so ein bisschen eine andere Perspektive reinzukommen,
um mal über den nächsten Tag hinaus zu denken.
Das kann die Gedanken doch sehr aufhellen.
So ist es. Die Grenzen des Wahlzettels sind die Grenzen unserer Zeit.
Egal, welche Meinung man noch auf Twitter schreibt. Ich schreibe ja keine Meinung mehr auf Twitter.
Ich halte meine Meinung jetzt zurück. Ich bin sehr gespannt, ob du dich daran hältst.
Ich retweete zwar immer noch ein bisschen was und lese viel.
Ich werde das überwachen und dich dann hier drauf überweisen.
Ich habe dich dieses Jahr schon retweetet.
Sehr gut. Und dann wollen wir auf den Salon verweisen.
Wer also diesen Podcast unterstützen möchte, worüber wir uns sehr freuen würden,
der kann den Salon dazu buchen und bekommt dafür auch was.
Nämlich wir diskutieren ja im Salon ausführlich über Lektüren.
Wir lesen immer ein Buch gemeinsam und dann stellt jeder noch Texte vor,
die im Monat wichtig waren.
Und wir haben dieses Mal gelesen, das nomadische Jahrhundert,
wie die Klimamigration unsere Welt verändern wird von Gaia Vins.
Sie ist Journalistin, auf allen Erdteilen schon zu Gast gewesen,
kennt sich aus, rezipiert unglaublich viele Studien.
Und die Zahlen, die sie uns da präsentiert, sind...
Erschreckend, überraschend, man notiert sich ständig etwas,
wir müssen unbedingt über Russland reden, denn da scheint ja eine Blütezeit
klimatisch bevor zu stehen und was bedeutet das dann auch geopolitisch,
es stehen so viele Sachen drin, Also dass man von vielen Dingen so inspirativ
ausgehen kann und dann überlegen kann, was bedeutet das eigentlich.
Sie sagt jedenfalls, Millionen, ja Milliarden Menschen werden ihre Heimat aufgrund
des Klimawandels in diesem Jahrhundert verlassen müssen.
Sie geht von verschiedenen Szenarien aus, aber auch wenn es so nicht das schlimmste
Szenario ist, das eintritt, aber wenn es eines ist, das doch auch das 1,5 Grad
Ziel reißt und davon gehen ja inzwischen alle aus,
dann hat das fundamentale Veränderungen für unglaublich viele Länder.
Einige Länder werden völlig unbewohnbar sein oder so sehr als Wüste uns erscheinen,
dass man dort nicht mehr leben will.
Es fragt sich also, wie regelt man die Migration? Ganz viele neue Städte müssen entstehen.
Darüber müssen wir unbedingt diskutieren. Da bin ich schon sehr gespannt drauf.
Jedes Grad mehr macht eine Milliarde Flüchtlinge. Und wir sind ja schon bei
1,46 laut EU-Kopernikus-Zentrum.
Also wo kommen die her, wo gehen die hin?
Darüber hinaus, ich habe mit einer Regel gebrochen, nämlich,
dass wir die Texte des Monats nehmen.
Ich nehme also einen Text von 2019, der uns aber jetzt, wie soll man sagen,
jetzt eigentlich noch aktueller ist als damals, weil wir jetzt so heuristisches
Material haben, Triggerpunkte und so weiter.
Es gab ja im Tagesspiegel eine große Wem gehört Berlin Reihe mit einem Aufschlagtext,
wer profitiert vom Berliner Mietmarkt 2019.
Und da werden die Namen genannt und die Verhältnisse, da gucken wir nochmal rein.
Dann habe ich eine Wutschrift eines über Jahrzehnte bei der NATO-Beschäftigten,
der über die Rolle der Militärexperten im Ukraine-Krieg im Fernsehen usw. geschrieben hat.
Bei Cicero, da geht es zur Sache. Die New York Times macht einen ganz launigen
Text darüber, dass die Mickey Mouse jetzt Copyright befreit ist.
Die 95 Jahre sind abgelaufen. Eigentlich hat Disney immer darauf Wert gelegt,
dass die Grenze ein bisschen rutscht. 95 Jahre war er jetzt ausgereizt,
also Mickey Mouse ist jetzt befreit.
In diesem Jahrzehnt noch Batman, Superman und so weiter.
Gerade jetzt im KI-Zeitalter, wo man so schnell Sachen generieren kann, wird es zur Sache gehen.
Horrorfilme mit Winnie Pooh und so stehen jetzt an.
Und dann zum Thema schlaflose Nächte.
Für alle, die sowieso über Vorjahressätze Vorsätze machen, was gibt es beim
Thema Schlaf noch zu bedenken? Wir lesen also heute mal wieder Brigitte.de.
Sehr schön, ja. Wir werden uns außerdem mit Mode beschäftigen.
Es ist eine Biografie über Jill Sander erschienen von Maria Wiesner.
Die habe ich mit großem Interesse und mit Freude gelesen.
Dann kennst du wahrscheinlich Nick Land.
Das ist dieser rechte Techno-Futurist, der in den 90er Jahren anfing zu publizieren,
jetzt bei den Alt-Right-Leuten ist und dessen Texte sind jetzt herausgegeben
worden bei Mattes und Seitz.
Das Interessanteste aber sind gar nicht die Texte, sondern ist die begleitende
Korrespondenz zwischen Philip Tyson und Dietmar Daat.
Und die schreiben sich E-Mails hin und her über Nick Land und generell über
die Linken und die Rechten.
Und das ist herausragend gut. Also es ist furios.
Man kann jeden beneiden, der mit Dietmar Daat im Im E-Mail-Verkehr steht.
Außerdem werden wir den Text von Robert Kagan lesen, ehemaliger Republikaner,
der dann zu einer Hillary Clinton, zu einem Hillary Clinton Anhänger wurde,
der sagt, es kommt eine Trump-Diktatur.
Bereitet euch jetzt schon mal davor, was das eigentlich bedeutet.
Und ich möchte noch eine Rezension, ich glaube das hatten wir noch nie,
eine Rezension besprechen im Salon.
Ann-Christine Clusty hat über das Buch von Geoffrey de Langeanerie geschrieben,
der ein Buch über Freundschaft und andere Beziehungsmodelle geschrieben hat.
Und es ist ein Verriss, ein sehr schöner Verriss, der sehr schönen Phänomene,
glaube ich, der linken intellektuellen Szene bloßlegt und darüber müssen wir unbedingt sprechen.
Sag uns noch, wie wir in den Salon kommen können.
Man geht auf neue20er.de und folgt dem goldenen Button in den Salon, vor allem über Steady.
Wir finden Steady, ein Berliner Unternehmen, also hier in Deutschland,
ganz gut. Das Paywall-Modell funktioniert.
Deswegen kann man dafür 2,50 Euro im Monat den Salon buchen.
Alternativ für 3,50 Euro bei Apple. Also für alle, die mit der Apple Podcast
App, für die ist es nämlich nur ein Klick.
Die haben ja eh schon 9,20 abonniert und sehen dann eine Folge im Abo, klicke ich mal.
Man kann aber auch, wenn man bei Steady Kunde ist, kriegt man einen eigenen RSS-Feed.
Den kann man dann auch in der Podcast-App, also man kann auch für 2,50 Euro
in der Apple Podcast-App den Salon hören, man muss es nicht für 3,50 Euro machen,
auch wenn es dann nur ein Klick ist und für alle, die schon einen Patreon-Account
haben, die gehen einfach zu Patreon.
Und ganz wichtig, ja man kann das dann auch über Spotify hören,
man kann auch den Salon über Spotify buchen, beziehungsweise ist da ein Button,
der einen dann zu steady führt und es ist gar kein Problem, das dann auch über Spotify zu hören.
Man muss nicht vor dem Laptop sitzen und kann dort nur noch den Podcast lauschen oder so.
Manchmal gibt es solche Fragen oder irgendjemand sagt schon mal,
sei gescheitert dabei, das reinzuführen.
Nein, es ist alles ganz, ganz einfach.
Und in der Regel gibt es auch nie Probleme und wenn, dann hilft Steady sofort.
Das heißt, ruhig trauen. Es gibt keine Schwierigkeiten eigentlich.
Ganz wichtiger Punkt jetzt. 2024, wir beginnen direkt im Januar damit,
wird ein Jahr der technischen Ermächtigung sein.
Nicht zuletzt, aber natürlich auch vor allem durch die künstliche Intelligenzwende.
Du bist ja auch eher ein Skeptiker. Ich werde uns die Skepsis austreiben dieses Jahr.
Und das bedeutet, wenn ihr Salon-Abonnenten seid...
Und ihr fragt euch, wo sind denn die Kapitelmarken und so weiter,
dann hört ihr den wahrscheinlich, indem ihr im Browser einfach bei Steady seid
und dort auf Play klickt.
Nur so hört man diesen Podcast nicht.
Man kriegt von Steady einen RSS-Feed und den lädt man in die Podcast-App seiner
Wahl mit mehreren Vorzügen.
Man wird benachrichtigt, wenn der Podcast da ist. Man kriegt das Cover angezeigt,
wo drauf steht Januar, Februar, März, April und so weiter.
Man weiß genau, wo man ist. Man kriegt Kapitelmarken dort angezeigt,
man kann hin und her springen, man kann sich Sachen markieren,
man kann Clips rausschneiden und so weiter und so fort, was die Podcast-Apps halt so bieten.
Ich möchte, dass alle Salon-Hörer richtige Podcast-Benutzer sind,
die das also artgerecht hören und dazu gehört übrigens auch ein bisschen höhere Geschwindigkeit.
Und wir werden schon das Datum nennen im Salon jetzt für unsere Sommershow,
werden aber noch nicht den Kartenverkauf starten können, das dauert noch mit
der Einrichtung bis Februar, aber diesen Termin gibt es und da ist dann auch Platz für 800 Leute,
das heißt da müssten eigentlich alle auf ihre Kosten kommen,
es sei denn es kommen jetzt alle drei, buchen alle zehn Karten,
aber ich weiß jetzt nicht.
Naja, also ich denke, es gibt eine gute Wahrscheinlichkeit und es ist schön
im August in Frankfurt, sofern kann man da vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen bleiben.
So ist es, es wird ein Wochenendtermin sein.
Sehr gut.
Bis gleich im Salon.
Bis gleich.